you know i'm asking the same question
you're asking it's like what's next like
what's the next thing so
let me just reverse psychoanalyze you um
so if values being something that you
talk about a lot and that lead to your
emotions which is essentially
your baseline and how you're feeling and
how your life really is like what do you
value then
well it's interesting because i think
you know values evolve throughout your
life
totally totally yeah and
some you know there are certain things
that
i didn't give too many [ __ ] about
before and now i'm starting to give more
[ __ ] um
you know health is kind of the easy
example there um
i like actually want to go to bed
but like i'm becoming an old man i'm
like want to be in bed by 10 you know i
get cranky if i'm not and it's just i
feel like my my 27 year old self would
be horrified if he saw what what i've
but like become
10 to 6 club
and i didn't choose to be here just
my biological clock just started doing
it uh much to my horror but um
but like
it's i would say you know
it's an interesting thing and i imagine
you've been through some similar
experiences in your own journey where
it's like
when you lev when you start leveling up
in your life like when you when you like
hit some big benchmarks
you hit some big success you gain a
platform you get a bunch of money
um
the questions start changing you know
and it's
it starts to become much much less of
like
you know oh [ __ ] what do i have to do to
make it and it becomes much more of like
okay how can i give back or
you know what's my legacy going to be um
or
you know how do i actually want to be
remembered um
or what are what are the opportunities
that i now have that i didn't have say
five ten years ago and so
i think a lot of this is kind of that
transition as well um i mean i i think
i'll always write and
i like writing books but
um
there's a lot of space
in between the writing like there's a
lot of
just time to do other things and to work
on other things and um
and so that's kind of like what i'm
trying to figure out at the moment is
that where writing will smith's book
came in where it was just kind of this
sort of trail off of like your own
content into someone else's have you
written other people's books i don't
know
no just his
that's really cool i mean was that part
of it was just kind of like a different
project that got you out of your space
and into someone else's well first of
all a lot of it had to do with who he is
you know it's like when the fresh prince
calls like you you take the you take the
meeting right
i remember a hundred years ago it was
like one of his sons was turning 16 or
something like that and their like team
reached out about me like making a video
and there's some compilation that was
going into his like video birthday party
thing and they asked and i was like oh
yeah of course like yeah yeah do you
just like make a video for some kid's
birthday for like well smith yeah it's
it's i've i never like aspired to write
a memoir or gosh write or write for a
celebrity or anything but yeah when it's
him it's like all right you go you go
talk to him and um
you know it was a great project i think
for me it was it was super interesting
just because what i get really excited
about and really interested in is is
just human psychology it's just it's why
do people do the things that they do why
do they what makes them tick
um why do we fail in certain ways and
succeed in others etc and
to me it's just he's like one of the
most interesting
case studies in the world right and uh
and so for me it was just
a pure joy to kind of get to know
not just him but like kind of what makes
him tick
his personality
um where he comes from the failures that
he's been through how he reacted to
those failures
and then on top of that you know like he
and i
we had a good chemistry i think
our skills balance each other out really
well like
he's always super like happy-go-lucky
positive like almost to a point where
it's a little delusional and
um and i'm just a cynical bastard and
it just like the
just want to like live in the darkness
um and so when we came together it was
actually a really nice balance you know
because it's
it
it ended up being
a very fun and cool project to kind of
do together um
but yeah i mean to kind of answer your
original question of like why i took it
i mean
aside from just the project being cool
um
you know subtle art blew up and became
so successful so quickly like vastly
more successful than i ever anticipated
that there was like a little bit i think
there were there were a couple years
where
uh
i guess you could probably call it
imposter syndrome a little bit of like
oh [ __ ] like
what if this is like my one thing you
know what if this never happens again
and what if this is like my one window
to like
you know
to like to make it count and and so i
just started saying yes to pretty much
anything that was you know
even remotely interesting uh
you're still doing that because you said
yes to my interview so
i'm actually not doing many interviews
anymore danica i'm super grateful yeah
no it's uh when you were a yes i was
like are you kidding me i was like are
you serious
no i mean it's it's i'm trying to back
off
the last year or two i'm trying you know
i've i'm not working on a book
most of my pro big projects are wrapped
at the moment i've cut i'm not doing
speaking at the moment and i've probably
cut back like 75 80 on interviews so
um so yeah it's it's uh
different seasons of a career or a life
you know that's part of life is the
seasons of life there's the micro
there's the macro you're going to have
your mini seasons within your days and
your weeks and you're going to have the
macro in your years and decades and
they're going to bring you something
different and i think giving that
permission having permission giving
yourself permission to be in those
different seasons is
um and also
sucking it up when it's time for a
season that's tough is like this is the
time right when you said this is my
moment i'm going to say yes to
everything and look where you are so you
can't argue that it didn't work before i
get into the heavier stuff that is all
about psychology because i'm super
fascinated with psychology psychology
science
spirituality any of those realms are my
my jam but i love psychology i'm reading
um i'm reading the book uh
um
the body keeps the score right now so oh
that's a great book
so anyway um do you think that maybe
there is some
effect from
will that
was this sort of happy-go-lucky
guy that rubbed off on you is there some
sort of epigenetic
um
uh
science experiment happening with you
where you just kind of saw this other
side or it brought out a side of you
that maybe you hadn't really
cultivated or gave enough time to
i think a little bit i wouldn't
characterize it in those same words i'll
say this he
ended up becoming a little bit of a role
model for me
um because i started working with him
like i said my career just blown up book
is
everywhere i'm getting invited on all
these tv shows and speaking events and
all this stuff and when it takes off and
people start recognizing you in the
street and and
events sell out like it starts [ __ ]
with your head a little bit and
and he was just a great role model of
like this is how you do it like he was
amazing he's amazing with his fans he's
amazing with his team he's great with
you know journalists and publicists and
everything he's got systems for
everything you know because he's just
been in this game forever definitely and
and so it was actually really useful to
be around him a lot you know because we
did a lot of interviews but there was
also just a lot of like i just kind of
tagged along and
went wherever he went and um
and so it was really really educational
and inspirational for me of like oh [ __ ]
like this is how you do it like this is
how you manage
you know
expectations of fans and this is how you
deal with the press and this is you know
when if
something shitty comes out on the
internet about you like you know this is
kind of the attitude that you should
have about it um
and so it was a real blessing in that
way for me
um it's funny because all the stuff
that's actually in the book or most of
the stuff that's in the book
um
you know it's
psychology personal development stuff
which i've been doing forever so it's
like there wasn't really
many
epiphanies for me personally
there you know from his story
um it was more like the professional
side of just seeing his professionalism
and his experience
and just how good he is at all that it's
always cool to be able to spend time
around people that um
you know live a different life no matter
what life it is you learn from learn
from ones that have an extravagant life
learn learn from ones that have a simple
life and
the best thing you can do is take
something from that so it sounds like
you have once you get on that path of
self development it's like i feel like
if you explain to somebody what it was
like to be on the path to
whatever you want to call it awakening
or
self-improvement development
it's it's like i feel like it's a ride
you never get off i i think of these
things in terms of skills right so it's
like we're developing emotional skills
we're developing communication skills
we're developing self-awareness as a
skill and most skills like you
to develop it there's like that process
of of
unconscious incompetence conscious
incompetence
conscious competence
unconscious confidence right like i
don't know if you've seen that grid
before but it's you know to learn
anything you have to start out by
becoming aware of all the things you're
bad at
and then from there you consciously work
on improving them
but then the final step is to actually
stop thinking about it at some point
right it's like if you if you're
learning how to ski
when you first learn you have to think
about everything you're doing you have
to think about how you're placing your
feet and how you're moving down the hill
and everything but at a certain point
that thinking is actually going to make
you worse and and to be and to be
excellent at it you actually have to
stop thinking about it
um
i lived that
i did a race car i drove a race car and
people asked is it hard to drive and i'm
like you don't think about the driving
yeah you got to make that the easy part
i mean if you if you were thinking in
the car by
it's probably too late like
trying to calculate passes and people
around me and pit stops and
oil and fuel you know oil temperature
water temperature do we need more tape
on the grill do i need this change with
the handling track bar tire pressure
what do i need you know
all of that stuff is going on as opposed
to just driving the car so you got good
at driving your car
yes and so i think at a certain point i
think what gets under publicized in the
personal development world is that final
step to unconscious competence of like
you know at some point you shouldn't
have to think about
you know every little thing in your
relationship you shouldn't have to think
about disciplining every minute of your
day you know because at a certain point
you're actually harming yourself
[Music]